hi welcome everyone so today i have a
very special video planned for you today
when i a couple of days ago asked on my
instagram account whether you would be
interested to see a video like that
i got an overwhelmingly positive
response i believe never did i get as
many people saying
yes please make this video and
specifically today i'm going to show you
how i
create a powerpoint presentation i will
let you look over my shoulders how i use
powerpoint for myself
and i will also share my thought process
why i
structure pages the way i do how i think
about structuring elements on a page so
all of this
will be included in this video and yes i
will give for the opportunity to also
download the sample slides in the end
there's a download link in the video
description where you can sign up and
then receive the file so welcome to
another coffee break here on my channel
firm learning
my name is heinrich i'm a former
mckinsey consultant
and on my channel i want to help you to
become successful
in the first years of your career now in
the video i want to find a good balance
of really
showing you what i'm doing and why i'm
doing it in detail but also speeding up
some sections where i'm just doing
things that is not that interesting
so i hope you will like it and i will
also try to not use
that many shortcuts to make it easier to
follow i might do a video specifically
on shortcuts at some point in the future
but frankly i'm not even using that many
shortcuts on powerpoint for sure there
are some that are really helpful but
this will not be the focus for today so
without further ado let's get into it
so before this video i asked myself okay
what presentation can i not really show
you because for obvious reasons i cannot
really guide you through an extra
presentation that i did for work so i
thought okay let me show you a
presentation that i potentially would do
maybe for a sponsorship partner
of this channel so as a youtuber
sometimes people approach me and ask me
if they can do a collaboration with me
so let's imagine i'd like to pitch my
channel from learning to such a partner
and how such a little pitch deck could
look like and indeed the first thing
that i usually like to do is to come up
with a storyline and specifically to
come up with the action titles of the
presentation so the titles that we put
here
in the beginning so we have no idea what
an action title is actually created a
whole video about that i will link it
somewhere above
so have a look at that really a
fundamental concept but let's start and
i'd say the first page is always a nice
page
where i introduce myself and the channel
so i could write something like this
from learning
is an educational video
consulting channel on social media
it's creator is i'm rich
a former mvp consultant
so this will potentially be a good first
slide where i
then insert the contents and indeed i
often also like to already make some
bullets what i will include
see i could for instance show my
audience and also an introduction of who
i am
okay what could be next and here i think
it's good to provide a little overview
of how the content looks like that i
create here on my from learning youtube
channel so here we could write something
like this
all right so this now could be a page
where i indeed talk about some things
that i'm doing so potentially an
overview of
from learning videos
that i could then be showing here to
this potential client of mine
okay next what would could you as the
next page in such a story and let's
imagine that already did a pilot for
this client where i tested out a
campaign
just to prove the value so i could write
something like this
from learning pilot so this could be now
a little chart where i show
exactly what the value looked like that
i provided
and some conclusions from that now
probably an overview of the pricing
the different contents that i could
offer would be helpful
so let's create such an overview for a
collaboration
in 2020 the following
packages could be offered
and then let's end with some contact
information
that i provide for them to be able to
contact me and again this will now be a
rather
short little presentation of course you
will probably flash this out a bit more
if you really would create such a deck
but i trust that this will provide a
little overview
of how all of this looks so let's start
with the first one actually let's start
with the title page
and here just inserted a more or less
random stock photo that shows a board
room setting
but let's start here with the title
so let's call it firm learning
collaboration
proposal and then often here as a
subtitle you can include something like
the month or the date and then also what
type of document potentially it is
for instance discussion document
so let's now start by filling this page
so one of the most
fundamental principles of slide design
that will really make your life
so much easier is the principle
every page is a table
every page or slide that you create in
powerpoint
is a table so always think about it like
a table
where you structure information in
columns and in
rows so here indeed we have no two types
of elements that we want to include here
first some information on the audience
and then some information
on myself right where i'm introducing
myself as
a creator and what i like to use when i
do
these kind of things are always little
column
headers because indeed we could not
structure this as the table where
probably the left side of the page
is about the audience so the left column
if you want to put it this way is the
audience
and then the right column the right side
of the page
is the introduction and i always like to
use an element like this i now copied it
over from
another document this is pretty much
just a text element
and this is just a line and then if you
do this together you can also
potentially
group it i use ctrl and g as a little
shortcut
as such an element so here let's call
this audience
and let's call this for the right-hand
side
introduction so this is now the basic
structure that you want your page to
take now the good next step is always to
think about
how do i know further structure these
two columns these two sites
so let's start with the audience and
here indeed we want to show
what the audience or firm learning looks
like right so how is it structured
and a good first straightforward step
might be just to show the
different social media channels that i
have
and again if you remind yourself that
every page is a table now here the
natural step the natural tendency that
you would want to lean to
is now indeed to structure it as rows
right if you have no different elements
that you want to show within such a
column
you use rows for that so let's now start
by creating rows for the different
social media
channels that i have so let's start here
with first youtube this is of course
largest channel that i use then next
we might have instagram and now let me
show you a little shortcut because if
you press
shift and control and then move an
element it creates a copy
and it keeps the axis fixed right so it
doesn't matter if you go up or down
or your left and right it keeps it fixed
that creates it on the same level right
this is of course extremely helpful for
things like that
so again i'm copying this over youtube
instagram
i have a firm learning
newsletter and i have
linked in i'd say these are my main
channels and again with these things
that always simplifies your life so much
if you make sure that all the elements
always have the same
widths because this will help you to
keep the whole page much more
organized you cannot just drag it a
little bit like this
and it will show you later why this is
so important
now this seems to have font size 18
let's make it a little bit smaller let's
make it font size
16 the one basic rule of slide writing
is to make sure that
all the text elements all the elements
in one page
with the exception being the action
title and the footnote
have the same font size right so let's
make sure that this is the case
okay now we take these four channels we
align them here to the left i always
like to use these little alignment
buttons
what you can see is here that i drag the
quick access bar
from the top here where it's usually
here now to this lower element because
this now reduces the distance
from my mouse to get there and this
really makes life easier for me so what
i did is now i highlighted this
highlighted this
then clicked here this align left button
to make it all on the same playing field
and indeed you know another little rule
of slight writing
so always what you like to do is think
about the page to be like a drawing
place right where usually then the
boundaries of the action title
are the boundaries of the page so you
want to make sure for it to have proper
margins
that nothing goes to the left of the
action title that nothing
goes beyond that so this is pretty an
imaginary little boundary
and then the same is through here to the
right where usually you like to end the
action title together here with the
footnote
and then nothing is supposed to be
further right than here the demarcation
that exists
by the right boundary of this page now
let's further think
of how we can structure it indeed now
let's further disaggregate this left
part
into two types of information so the
first is
the platform this is now what we already
did here
but then we also want to include a
second column and you know i did the
same
copying trick that i showed you with the
shortcut where i talk about the
firm learning audience and this is then
supposed to give us
the audience size and here indeed on
youtube i have
85 000 sub scribers
so this is pretty much my audience that
i currently have at this very moment
now let's further style the section so i
like to do to have the column headers
in bold and black but then if i want to
focus on
any other elements within the columns i
like to bold them
but then not in black but personally i
like to use
a dark blue right so this creates a
little hierarchy among the elements
because of course black is darker than
dark blue here of course you could now
highlight these numbers again make sure
to
make them blue just to
format this in a proper way now you
could further style it by for instance
increasing now the font size zero of the
numbers so let's for instance increase
it to
font size 40. so this is of course now a
little deviation from the rule that i
told you that everything needs to look
exactly the same in terms of font size
but of course sometimes little
deviations like this are allowed if it
improves
the overall look and feel even though i
would encourage you to follow this rule
rather strictly
for most cases so another little thing
that you can do to further improve the
look and feel of this page is to include
little icons for these platforms
so i did a video on this topic in the
past i will also include it somewhere
above here
they are also recommended you a service
that i also personally use
to really draw icons because of course
if you just download them somewhere in
the
google picture search that you often
have a problem with copyright
but if you use the service simple slides
you can have access to a large
library of icons all of them are for you
copyright free if you have the
subscription you can also use it for
commercial purposes so i can very much
recommend this if you're interested to
try out simple slides for yourself
there's a link to that in the video
description as well so in the meantime
already selected a couple of icons that
i took
from simple slides they also have icons
for the different social media platforms
so i'm just copying them in here of
course these
look a bit weird in terms of the color
here would also be great to have
this dark blue type of look and this is
exactly what we will
get us here so let's now include them a
bit and now it's great to potentially
insert them to the left
of your slides so let's move this a
little bit to the right
let's move this to the right as well and
now we have some space here
where we can include these little icons
so now another little thing to further
tidy all this up
is to use separation lines so this is
also
very very common element to use and to
do this you pretty much include a line
like this
i often like to format this in some
light gray
and then also some dashes here that you
can use
again here make sure that this properly
starts
here to the left and then also ends here
to the right of this element and then
with the same trick that i showed you
earlier
you can copy this over here now if you
are this far
you can then group the different
elements
you drag this to the bottom where you
want to start it all you drag this
to the top where you want to let this
start then you highlight all
this potential also here to have it
evenly spaced out align it this way
and then it's properly and evenly
distributed
so let's now move here to the left side
so to the introduction part so first now
it would be great to also visually
separate this a little bit more from the
right side of this light
so for that we can add here another line
for such a
separation line then it makes sense to
also make it a
solid line maybe increase the weight a
little bit more
now make sure that this nicely ends here
to the right
where i showed you here to the end of
the footnote and now you can use some
space
to include some text about myself
so we could for instance call this meet
the creator
so pretty much meet me as the creator of
firm learning and then to further
elaborate on this
so what could make sense in such a
situation is to start by for instance
including a photo
i just copied over a photo of myself of
course
introduce myself and then maybe here on
the right you might
want to include some text
so for instance my name with career
and consulting
content something like this is what you
could include
then again you highlight this
you make it dark blue to bold it
and then you center it or line it here
so this could be now this element and
then maybe here in some bullets below
i'd like to include some information
about
myself also in the sense of a mini cv a
mini curriculum retail
so just a couple of things that you
could
include here right you can move this
up a little potentially move this
a little bit down maybe you now realize
that
it would be nicer to align this more to
the
bottom to have it more evenly spaced out
of course all of this could be done now
and now it's also always a great idea
to potentially build a couple of key
pieces of information
that you would like to include okay
so this could be now the first page that
you could use in such a deck
so let's now do the second page and here
what i just like to show is a very basic
page
where i show different examples of
thumbnails of my youtube videos
just to give the impression of what my
topic is all about what my videos are
like
so indeed if you do something like this
it makes sense to also include a little
header
so i will include a little header as
this saying exemplary
firm learning content selected youtube
thumbnails right and again here what i
like to do is whenever i have
a little extra information i like to
unbold it and then use here
a little gray color to just make it look
nice but this is my personal preference
other people might use different styles
now let's insert a couple of pictures of
thumbnails of my videos
so here we go and indeed now as always
with these
things alignment is important so these
are now 12 pictures
so that's roughly align them
in three rows with
four columns each
so something like this
but now of course we need to be properly
aligned to the boundary so here to the
left
here to the right
now the rows to each other
what then you can do if you do something
like this is always to include
for instance a little picture border
to make it look properly
but then i'd say this really is a good
proper page that you can very well use
for such a purpose
now next page and here you remember that
we wanted to show
some results of a pilot that i did maybe
in the past with this specific client
so the basic structure that you can
follow when you work like this when you
work with numbers and create a chart
is that to the left you have a column
with exactly that so the chart
and then to the right you have a column
with some implications some conclusions
that you want to make so first what we
do is that as always we include some
headers for these columns
so this will now be for the chart where
we say sources of the users numbers of
users indicated by client
and then to the right you potentially
write something like yeah let's just
call it
conclusions right and now we want to
include a chart so i will now
use uh think cell which is a
plugin for powerpoint it's a plugin very
widely uncommonly used by consulting
firms most large consulting firms use it
but also corporate firms use it it's
really great to create charts
but of course you can do these things
with the build and powerpoint
chart creation tools as well so i will
now spare you the details of how exactly
you need to work with things seller
created here such a very very basic
think cell waterfall chart where we say
okay total new clients then what did
from learning contribute as a source
what came from paid facebook ads and
what came from other channels
and here's just what i want to say is
that you need to be very very
careful and rather sparse with the
colors so
don't really use lots of colors don't
make it super powerful
usually it's good to make it for
instance all in grey and then i just did
this in dark blue
just to emphasize what was coming from
my channels what was coming from from
learning
now next you can continue by adding some
information to some conclusions some
insights that you are drawing
from all of this so let's just as always
copy over this
text field let's fix here the font size
of font
16 and now we can
insert some text so now in order for you
not needing to just watch me type a lot
i just copy here the text over with a
couple of information here
and this is now indeed what we will use
for this let's now maybe space it out a
little bit better
but now here we have such a page where
we indeed show a chart of the results
and then provide some conclusions and
insights that we are drawing from that
let's now do this page where indeed i
want to talk about the different service
packages that we could offer
what these would include and then also
some price tags in the end
so let's imagine that we have three
different service packages that we would
be willing to offer
and here again in the table format if
you have three different elements
you can make sure to organize them in
three columns
so let's just imagine we call them level
one the core package
intermediate package and the advanced
package so just
pre-created these headers for you
so you see these are just a very basic
same headers
that we were already using and then here
in the rows what do we put here in the
rows
and here one mistake that many people
are doing is
on such an instance just to create a
page like this
include some bullets like this
and then just create a long list of
different bullets
right so now that'll be writing
something but a long list of stuff
where you detail all types of different
things this always looks
very very unstructured and not
professionally
this is what you call a cloth line right
so a long clothesline list of randomly
unstructured bullets
so whenever you do things like that
think about how could you
structure the bullets into logical
groups
into groups of elements that well fit
together and this is exactly what we
want to do here
and because here now we want to describe
the service package what we are offering
you of course it makes sense to then use
the different social media channels that
we are offering
and then what we would do in each of
these packages and then maybe in the end
is the last row the pricing for all of
this
so in these instances what i like to do
is to use a little
boxes like this so here for instance we
could use a light blue
then as a border a dark blue and now in
this
box you know organize the things right
and we you know
do one box for every
channel so make it real i usually like
to use arial as a basic font because i
believe it
looks nice and clean in most cases and
now we
do this for all the different channels
that we introduced earlier
so youtube instagram and here just a
general rule so what you should really
notice and memorize is that whenever you
have now a set of elements that repeat
throughout the document here for
instance this would be the different
platforms the different social media
channels that you use
make sure that they always appear in the
same order as you initially
introduce them it's always super
confusing if you have
a set of pages like this where you talk
about the different channels
and then on the one page it starts with
youtube on the other page with instagram
and then with another one
always keep it in the same order this
will help you to keep this
organized and clean and nice to follow
now of course it would in these cases
also be nice
to use the same icons that you used here
on the page before
now in order for you to not see me type
too much
i just now created different text boxes
of bullets
now of course we could also use
separator lines here so let me copy some
in here as well
so let's now also make sure to include
some content here in the bottom for this
content editing and production part
and now what you could do is include a
little arrow to make sure that this
last one is really relevant for all the
three packages right so it's the same
for all these three packages that you're
offering
so you could use an error like this
maybe make it even a little bit
bolder well now even if you make this up
front it does look a little bit
weird and here what you can do is to
then include a little box
that you just make white you again
properly center it here in the middle
and then you do this to the end you do
this to the end as well
you line all of this and now you have
such a formation which looks
more or less great so let's now align
this properly as well here again
you can group these different row
elements as always
something you learn this by now now it's
all
nicely and evenly spaced as you can see
this does look a bit weird so something
is off here
so let's see what is causing this and
this is caused because this is here
included in the group so let's ungroup
it again
let's group it and let's align it as
well
to now fix it now finally though you
might want to include a line
with the commercials in the very end to
also indicate
how expensive such a package would be
to your client so let's just take some
text here
let's align it here to the left let's
call this
commercials and now indeed you can
include
how expensive exactly all these
different packages
are supposed to be always a lining
lining is the most important thing to
make it look
nice and clean and now here you can
insert
the euro amounts and here i will leave
it to your imagination
what you could charge for these packages
again if you have this one final
alignment
will not hurt
and now you're good for this page let's
maybe move all of this up a little bit
and then you are fine now last but not
least
let's include some contact information
here
this is of course nice and
straightforward this is something that
you can easily do here in the end
so you could just do a nice page like
this
not over style it so if you create
something like this
this will usually be more than fine for
last page
with contact information so this is it a
very basic
little document that we now jointly
created
as a little pitch deck for a typical
influencer marketing collaboration
so for sure this is now not yet super
polished there are several things that
you could not do to further improve this
and of course if you would really create
such a deck probably would expand on it
a little bit more you would go into more
detail
of how these packages would look like
you would go into more detail of how
your content looks like
or what you could do for the brand but i
hope that this gives you a good first
impression and i hope that i was
successful in really guiding you through
my thought process
and helping you to understand how i
would tackle
such a task if i would need to create
such a presentation
so as always if you have any questions
on this do leave me a comment in the
comment
section i will do my very best to answer
every single comment that you write
also if you want to have the slides that
we just created for yourself i also
included a link in the video description
where you can download this little deck
and please if you took any value out of
this video at all please hit the like
button for the youtube algorithm and
also subscribe to the channel to stay up
to date on all my content you can also
follow me on instagram my handle is firm
learning
also have an email newsletter sign up
link in the video description
and of course also feel free to reach
out on linkedin
again link to that in the video
description now big thanks to the
members of firm learning you're really
amazing
my name is heinrich i'm releasing new
videos every single saturday
so looking forward to next week until
then good weekend to all of you
cheers this is sani from from learning